j'ai réservé on voit tous et fabien
roussel est notre invité politique c'est
mettre un bonjour merci beaucoup joué
avec le député du nord 5 internationales
du parti communiste ancien candidat à la
présidentielle et on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par julien lécuyer de la voix
du nord bonjour julien bonjour yann
bonjour monsieur roux sajoo on va
évidemment parler de ce qui se passe à
gauche et de ses discussions pour
trouver un accord pour les législatives
est ce qu'il y aura un accord entre le
parti communiste et l'union populaire
pour ces législatives et la france en
sont
nous voulons tout faire pour susciter
cet espoir à gauche de construire une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale pour
que dès le mois de juillet il y est tout
de suite des mesures pour augmenter les
salaires et tous les salaires dans le
privé comme dans la fonction publique
pour que tout de suite nous puissions
bloquer les prix de certaines factures
et baisser celle de l'énergie et pour
tout de suite mettre en place un plan
d'embauché pour nos hôpitaux pour nos
soignants mais aussi dans les ehpad il y
à des mesures à prendre dès le mois de
juillet et nous le ferons si nous avons
une majorité de députés de gauche qui
réunira des insoumis des communistes des
socialistes des écologistes sur un
contrat de législature donc vous voyant
en quelques secondes je viens de vous
dire quelle est l'ambition que nous
voulons former une grande coalition et
susciter cet espoir que oui il est
possible de mettre en place cette
majorité est donc d'empêcher le
président de la république élu de mettre
en oeuvre sa réforme de retraite de 65
ans et de continuer de nous faire les
pollutions est ce que les conditions
sont réunies pour cet accord de
législature
l'ambition la comprendre et le diable se
cache dans les détails on exactement
alors allons chercher le diable il y a
aujourd'hui sur le papier
la possibilité de le faire
d'abord il y a trois blocs politiques
qui se sont constitués à l'issue du
premier tour d'élection présidentielle
l'extrême droite avec marine le pen mais
plusieurs courants à l'extrême droite la
droite dans laquelle j'ai inclus le
président de la république le libéral
avec plusieurs courants aussi et puis la
gauche avec
30% des électeurs réunis avec jean luc
mélenchon mais aussi plusieurs
sensibilités qui se sont exprimés et
nous sommes tous à un tiers et donc
qu'il ya un enjeu pour chacun de ces
blocs de construire cette majorité une
majorité ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
en gagner jean luc mélenchon a réuni un
peu plus de 7 millions de voix mais
l'ensemble des autres forces de gauche
c'est trois millions et demi de voix il
va falloir additionner cela alors
aujourd'hui
nous discutons nous discutons pour
former cette coalition ce que nous
souhaitons nous c'est un rassemblement
dans lequel il y est tout le monde tout
le monde lance les roses millions
d'électeurs doivent être représentés
puisque il va falloir en chercher plus
pour construire une majorité et il faut
qu'il y ait le respect des sensibilités
c'est à dire que chacun puisse se sentir
respecté dans le programme que nous
avons défendues puisque nous avons eu
des programmes qui sont convergence sur
un grand nombre de biens on vous révèle
aussi diverses que je respecte mais
surtout seul lors des négociations avec
les insoumis aujourd'hui dans les
discussions que nous avons
je dirais à ce stade qu'elle piétine et
que ça n'avance pas ça n'avance pas
assez vite en tout cas ces négociations
piétinent parce que nous n'avons pas le
sentiment que toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour pouvoir enclencher cette
dynamique qu'est ce qui manque alors
pour enclencher ce rassemblement pour
pouvoir respecter l'ensemble des forces
qui sont présentes et y compris la nôtre
ce qui manque c'est que on arrive à
passer
d'un ralliement à l'union populaire avec
un logo et un homme à un rassemblement
qui respecte l'ensemble des forces et
qui nous permettent d'enclencher une
dynamique sur l'ensemble du territoire
sur dans tous les départements de france
et d'outre-mer et avec des candidatures
des hommes des femmes qui non seulement
peuvent se retrouver dans un contrat de
législature qui nous rassemble tout ce
qu'ils nous respectent tous mais aussi
des candidatures qui s'appuie sur des
ancrages locaux sur des personnalités
locales en capacité de l'envié mais quel
est votre sentiment de faire au sel on a
du mal à saisir on a l'impression que
vous êtes tous autour du buffet mais que
les insoumis veulent la grande majorité
du buffet il réclame trop de vous bon
c'est pas forcément une question de trop
ou de pas assez puisque ces discussions
nous les aurons quand même et
effectivement il faut aboutir vite oui
lui dit vous même c'est une question de
dynamique que nous devons réussir à
enclencher
trouve une trop grande et germaniques
jean luc mélenchon ils en demandent trop
autour de lui c'est ça le construire un
rassemblement est enclenché une
dynamique dans l'ensemble du pays pour
non seulement additionner les 7 millions
de voix de mélenchon et les trois
millions et demi de voix des autres
forces de gauche ça ne peut pas être
ralliez vous à mon programme ralliez
vous à mon logo et avec un objectif
élisez moi premier ministre c'est pas un
homme c'est pas un parti c'est pas un
logo rassemblement et donc nous devons
construire les moyens de définir
ensemble un contrat de législature dans
laquelle chacun se retrouve et bien sûr
et nous nous le disons et nous l'avons
dit à la france a soumises mettons de
côté ce qui fait nos différences et sur
lesquels nous n'arriverons pas à nous
entendre mais si l'objectif est
justement de construire une majorité
c'est pas dans un seul groupe il faut
qu'il y ait un groupe pour chacune des
forces politiques qui nous permettent
ensuite de défendre ce qui fait aussi
nos différences et donc nous voulons
construire un contrat de législature
et puis construire une dynamique sur
l'ensemble du territoire et donc pour
cela il faut que nous puissions nous
mettre d'accord sur l'ensemble des
départements sur russell est ce que vous
pensez que les insoumis sont prêts à ça
ce contrat de législature quand on voit
par exemple que leur première affiche de
campagne
c'est jean luc mélenchon et ce titre
élisez moi premier ministre et ce qui a
pas là une personnification du pouvoir
une forme de de disparition derrière
derrière lui de toutes les autres
formations de gauche c'est vrai que ça
donne ce sentiment est
nous qui luttons nous qui luttons pour
une nouvelle république contre le
présidentialisme des élections nous
voulons rétablir une véritable
démocratie qui repose sur le parlement
je regrette que mon présidentialise
aussi l'élection législative que l'on
présidentialise à ce point le parlement
au contraire le parlement c'est 577
députés et des sénateurs mais c'est 577
députés à l'assemblée nationale qui
représente une diversité d'opinions et
donc cette diversité d'opinion alors de
gauche de droite mais aussi à gauche
elle doit refléter justement la
diversité de pensée des français de nos
concitoyens ce que je souhaite c'est que
nous arrivions aujourd'hui au stade où
nous en sommes et les salles échéance
approche vite les élections c'est le 12
juin le dépôt des candidatures s'est mis
mais il faut que nous arrivions à
surmonter les difficultés auxquelles
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui je le
souhaite je la sais quoi précisément les
difficultés les points d'achoppement
c'est quoi bien je pense que pour
surmonter ces difficultés il faudrait
d'abord que nous arrivions à nous
rencontrer ensemble les quatre forces
politiques c'est ce que j'appelle de mes
voeux aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y ait une
plénière une rencontre de l'ensemble des
quatre forces politiques qui chacun
d'entre nous avons rencontré les
insoumis pour pouvoir ensemble d'abord
imaginé le label images que nous
pourrions renvoyer aux électeurs de dire
nous discutons et nous avons la volonté
de gagner ensemble je pense que le
succès de ce rassemblement et beaucoup
peint d'excès à l'espoir que nous allons
donner et donc je souhaite que nous
puissions nous retrouver ensemble et que
ensemble dans une discussion qui nous
respecte on puisse lever les différents
points de blocage qui existe aujourd'hui
il faudrait
il faut que l'on arrive à respecter les
différentes sensibilités que nous
incarnons c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il
faut trouver le contrat de législature
qui nous rassemble le ce programme
commun et il peut pas faire 300 pages on
va pas faire ça mais c'est qu'elle
considère forte
traitement encore une fois sur quelles
propositions ça peut il faut absolument
négocier selon vous c'est pas négocier
c'est se mettre d'accord sur les dix
propositions que nous nous engageons de
mettre en oeuvre dès le mois de juillet
un contrat de législature et retraite à
60 ans et que l'on peut se mettre et
nous pouvons nous mettre d'accord
rapidement là dessus ces hausses des
salaires hausse du smic et des salaires
ligne adhérents 1400 c'est ce que nous
proposons c'est des gel du point
d'indicé pour l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires ces blocages des prix
pour les produits de première nécessité
et baisses des applications vas y c'est
abrogation des lois elle comrie et des
ordonnances macron qui ont tellement
fait de mal aux organisations syndicales
ce sont des points que nous nous
mettrait fin d'année vers le maine le
nucléaire ça c'est un point de blocage
puisque j'ai été le seul à défendre à
mix énergétique avec et détruisant les
écologistes sont pas prêts de faire un
run et un homme sur le nez mais je
respecte tout à fait ces différences qui
existent parmi nous mais justement la
meilleure chance que nous devrions nous
donner c'est de nous mettre d'accord sur
des points qui touchent le pouvoir
d'achat les services publics mettons de
côté cette question là mais laissons la
possibilité à ce qu'il n'y ait demain
groupe écologiste à l'assemblée
nationale qui dira non au nucléaire et
un groupe communiste qui dira à nouveau
un mix énergétique
il a laissé la construction de deux
groupes de trois groupes de quatre
groupes parlementaires différents mais
qui se mettra d'accord ensemble apporter
des points communs qui va toucher tout
de suite à l'amélioration de la vie nos
concitoyens notamment de leurs souhaits
fabien en scène ce matin c'est que les
candidats communistes et sous
l'étiquette communiste pareil pour les
socialistes par est présentement par les
écologistes chacun a son groupe et vous
faites un contrat de législature mais
chacun y va de sa propre étiquette c'est
pas forcément une question d'étiquette
même si cette question elle est posée
mais je pense que nous pouvons nous nous
proposons nous proposons de nous
rassembler derrière ou un label commun
mais qui serait celui que nous pouvons
construire ensemble la rapidement et
qu'ils nous respectent tous dans lequel
chacun insoumis écologistes socialistes
communistes nous puissions nous
retrouver donc créons ce jalon son
groupe appelait créons le secret ont
chacun ce label commun il n'y a pas
d'opposition à ce que chacun ait son
groupe ça on nous sommes tous d'accord y
compris à ce que nous puissions nous
retrouver ensemble pendant la
législature dans un intergroupe où nous
pouvons communiquer préparer les textes
de lois etc mais que chacun est son
propre groupe nous sommes tous d'accord
là dessus nous pouvons nous mettre
d'accord sur un label commun c'est ce
que nous nous proposons et halak à la
belle dans lequel chaque sensibilité se
retrouve une plateforme un contrat de
l'est isla tueur un programme qui
rassemble en deux trois pages les points
sur lesquels nous serons d'accord pour
nous battre ensemble et puis une
représentation sur l'ensemble des
territoires dans lesquels nous pouvons
permettre à tous les militants et à tous
les électeurs de se retrouver
aujourd'hui dans les discussions que
nous avons
on est loin du compte et très très loin
du compte là pour aujourd'hui nous ne
pourrions pas nous présenter dans 90% du
territoire français dont vous imaginez
bien c'est à dire que concrètement le ce
n'est pas possible
il faut voir les calculs que vous ont
soumis les non seulement créer les
conditions d'une démarche dans
lesquelles tout le monde se retrouve et
qui suscite une dynamique et susciter
une dynamique c'est respecter aussi
les forces en présence les personnalités
qui existe dans l'ensemble des
départements c'est fait
on n'en est pas là aujourd'hui je vais
vous dire aujourd'hui on en est un sur
l'idée est ce qu'on peut se mettre
d'accord sur un label commun sur un
contrat de législature commun et est-ce
qu'on est d'accord pour avancer à quatre
ensembles moi je je je dirais que c'est
même presque un préalable c'est que nous
y soyons à 4 et que nous avancions en ce
sens dès qu'il ya trop de conciliabules
selon vous des insurgés avec les
écologistes avec les socialistes je ne
dirais pas trop parce que c'était bien
que l'on se voit chacun et que chacun
est à se dire ce que l'on a à nous dire
entre nous ça a été fait maintenant je
pense que les choses sont mûrs pour que
l'on puisse nous voir tous ensemble
c'est le souhait que je formule et
qu'ensemble on puisse afficher notre
détermination à surmonter les
difficultés qui rêve et à aller ensemble
plus unis possible dans vos le plus de
votre ambition est sur vous ce serait
par exemple que le 1er mai on puisse
faire la photo de fabien roussel avec
jean luc mélenchon avec olivier faure
avec julien bayou sur la première ligne
des manifestations
bien sûr pourquoi pas ce sera un signal
important pour l'ensemble du monde du
travail de voir que nous sommes prêts
à défiler ensemble et et à montrer notre
détermination à gagner ces élections
législatives et je suis prêt à le faire
et je dirais même qu'on a une lourde
responsabilité d'abord parce que
beaucoup d'électeurs attendent ce
rassemblement et nous voulons le créer
nous voulons sincèrement créer les
conditions de ce rassemblement mais je
dirais aussi que il faut mesurer et je
crains que tout le monde ne mesure pas
le risque qu'il y as pour l'extrême
droite de l'emporter dans un grand
nombre de circonscriptions il y a
aujourd'hui 160 circonscriptions où
l'extrême droite réunies 50 et plus de
55 cent des électeurs
c'est énorme ça veut dire que dans ces
circonscriptions y compris il y à des
députés de gauche
concernés dans ces circonscriptions
votre circonscription dans l'avion qui
jusque dans votre dont la mienne mais
pas que il y a des députés insoumis des
députés socialistes des députés
communistes qui sont aujourd'hui dans
des circonscriptions où le front
national fait plus de 50% on ne peut pas
prendre ça à la légère et on a une
obligation d'être unis dans ces
circonscriptions et de tout faire pour
que le front national ne l'emportent pas
là où aujourd'hui il fait plus de 50% et
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup d'électeurs au
second tour qui ont utilisé le bulletin
de vote de marine le pen non pas pour
soutenir son projet mais pour rejeter
macron et pour le dégager ya eu un vote
dégagé au second tour d'élection
présidentielle
nous devons donc leur parler leur parler
et leur présenter un projet et leur
montrer que la leur vie peut changer
tout de suite dès le 1er juillet en
étant unis et vous êtes le seul à
vouloir faire cette photo de famille
vous vous sentez que certains qui
pourrait se laisser tenter non je
formule cette proposition je lance cet
appel à ce que nous puissions nous
retrouver au 1er mai au moins pour
défiler ensemble et sinon là cet après
midi demain pour dire nous sommes prêts
à composer la proposition a déjà été
lancée vous les avez eue au téléphone
vous l'avez jeu la formule ici cette
proposition mais je l'ait déjà évoqué
lors de précédents échanges que j'ai eus
conférence de presse justement puisqu'on
parle du 1er mai ce que dimanche vous
appeler les français à descendre dans la
rue quel message vous l'envoyez emmanuel
macron à l'occasion
le message c'est de dire que qu'ils
entendent bien qu'une grande majorité de
français aujourd'hui soixante dix pour
cent d'après un sondage ne veulent pas
de la réforme des retraites qui vise à
repousser l'âge de départ à 65 ans une
grande majorité de français ne veulent
pas de cette réforme il faut qu'il
entende que s'il a eu 58 % des voix au
second tour de cette élection
présidentielle avec un taux d'abstention
record d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un vote
d'adhésion à son programme ce n'est pas
un vote d'adhésion à sa réforme des
retraites il faut qu'il entende que
beaucoup de français avec
esprit de responsabilité ont dit non à
marine le pen ont dit non à l'extrême
droite et qu'il respecte ce vote là moi
même j'ai appelé à ce vote là et que ce
n'est pas un vote d'adhésion à son
programme et c'est pour ça que cette
mobilisation du 1er mai doit être la
plus forte possible pour qu'il entende
que nous sommes mobilisés et que ce que
nous voulons ce sont des réformes
heureuse progressistes comme je les ai
défendu pendant la campagne des
élections présidentielles on veut que ça
change dans le bon sens que l'on vive
mieux que l'on ait des perspectives
heureuses dans les années à venir pour
les salariés pour le monde du travail et
pour la jeunesse hier aujourd'hui se
tient dernier conseil des ministres
de jean castex a priori est ce que il
hier à cergy emmanuel macron a dit qu'il
souhaitait un premier ministre attaché à
la question sociale environnementale et
productive ça vous rassure ça
ça veut rien dire il ya tout et
n'importe quoi non pas
d'accord vous aider alors très dur c'est
quand même visiblement ils donnent une
tonalité plus tôt en données sociales
environnementales
ne croyait pas une seule seconde visible
mais il ya elle a sorti une phrase qui
dure six secondes et tout le monde la
commentant dira c'est lui c'est un tel
cas on n'en sait rien mais que ce qui
compte c'est le programme qui va être
mise en oeuvre ce qui compte
il peut faire un virage à droite et
l'habiller de social ça marchera pas non
mais
on connaît macron sa politique on sait
pour qui il travaille pour la finance
essentiellement c'est ce qu'il a fait
pendant cinq ans et donc ce qui est
important je reviens là dessus je suis
désolé mais la politique du gouvernement
elle est déterminée par la majorité qui
existera à l'assemblée nationale est
donc
déterminant mais mais bien sûr enfin
vous l'avez vu aussi ça aujourd'hui
avant on tapait sur la cohabitation en
disant ça empêche de gouvernement
aujourd'hui il ya une majorité de
français qui disent que ce président de
la république a été élu par défaut et
que oui nous souhaitons une cohabitation
pour avoir une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale qui met en oeuvre des réformes
qui défendent le monde ouvrier monde du
travail la genèse qui attendent les
jeunes qui attendent un revenu
d'allocations autonomie pour la rentrée
de septembre qui n'en peuvent plus
parcours su enfin sur tous ces points là
je suis heureux d'ailleurs que les
forces de gauche je le disais pendant ma
campagne nous sommes d'accord pour la
jeunesse pour le revenu étudiants pour
le défi climatique a beaucoup beaucoup
de sujets sur lesquels nous sommes
rassemblés et nous pourrons tout de
suite déposer des textes de loi commun
visant à cela mais pour que ces textes
de lois l'emportent et il faut une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale alors
vous serez 4 on a compris mais il y aura
qu'un premier ministre si jamais vous
l'emportez ça veut dire que vous êtes
d'accord pour que jean luc mélenchon
sera premier ministre c'est là où tu es
moi j'ai aucune difficulté là dessus je
l'est ce qui compte c'est la majorité
d'abord on n'élit pas jean-luc mélenchon
premier ministre c'est une section ça
c'est ça c'est un slogan
on sait cette affiche non je désapprouve
pas mais je c'est une
présidentialisation de du parlement de
des élections législatives et je trouve
que ça ne donne pas ça ne fait pas
mesuré l'enjeu qu'il ya derrière ces
élections la première étape c'est
d'abord de construire une majorité est
ce que vous entendez ces mots construire
construire ça veut dire additionner se
retrouver bâtir des groupes construits
localement dans les départements dans
les circonscriptions quand je vois qu'il
y a des belles candidatures qui se
construisent jean marc tellier avions
michel picard à vénissieux qui ont la
possibilité de l'emporter danser dans
ces circonscriptions je me dis
construisons avec eux avec elle et dans
toute la france une majorité qui avec un
groupe insoumis importants et sont
arrivés en tête lors des élections
présidentielles à gauche avec un groupe
communiste écologiste qui n'en a pas
c'est une anomalie et avec un groupe
socialiste ensemble nous pouvons
construire un contrat de législature et
porter cet immense espoir c'est
important fabien roussel vous avez été
évidemment le candidat du parti
communiste à la présidentielle vous avez
fait un plus de 2% des voix est ce
qu'aujourd'hui avec un peu de recul vous
êtes déçu de son score ce qui est
décevant c'est de voir
l'immense énergie que nous avons pu
mettre collectivement dans cette
campagne et qui à la fin est réduite par
cette aspiration par ces personnes qui
comptait voter pour moi qui à la
dernière minute ont chargé leur bulletin
en se disant avec c'est ce mode de
scrutin qu'ils qualifient que les deux
premières en tête avec ces sondages qui
disait mélenchon pas arriver au second
tour on va voter mélenchon votre pub
pour nos idées on va voter pour
mélenchon il faut changer ce système
je pense que ça ça ça fait mal en même
temps j'entends je vois d'ailleurs dès
que je sors le capital sympathie qu'il
ya autour de ma candidature et de ce que
j'ai porté ça va compter aussi pour
l'avenir tant mieux c'est un point
d'appui et donc je ne suis pas du tout
déçu de cela je pense que malgré tout
nous avons réussi à développer des idées
qui n'auraient pas été développée si ma
candidature n'avait pas été présente je
suis fier de cela et tous ceux qui ont
milité pour cette campagne dans toute la
france sont fiers de cela alors imaginez
l'appétit qu'ils ont aujourd'hui de
pouvoir continuer à militer et à
défendre le programme des jours heureux
dans un programme de législature pour
former une majorité mais ils sont là ils
sont sur la ligne de départ prêt à
défendre cette grande ambition pour la
fait ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui vous là
vous la regrettée pas à cette
candidature mais même si jean luc
mélenchon est passé à un petit peu nous
mais vous avez raison monsieur l'écuyer
le problème d'abord c'est quand même les
institutions ce mode de scrutin enfin
vous vous rendez compte que jean luc
mélenchon aurait pu faire dit vous à
moins que marine le pen il n'était pas
qualifié parce que ce mode de scrutin
particulièrement injuste ne retient que
les deux qui arrive en tête pas les
trois pas ceux qui font plus de 10 comme
aux élections cantonales ou boudent plus
de douze ennemis comme aux élections
législatives au moins là y ait un peu de
justice il peut y avoir une triangulaire
même une quadrangulaire et ben aux
élections présidentielles n'y est rien
que dalle voilà il faut changer le
principe deux finales et bien sûr si au
moins on avait fait ça mais ça devrait
quand même la possibilité pour les
électeurs de voter pour le candidat de
son choix afin qu'ils fassent plus de
10% et d'ailleurs je vais proposer de
lancer une grande campagne en france
pour réformer ce mode de scrutin et
garantir beaucoup plus de justice
démocratie dans le choix du candidat à
la présidentielle oh mais ils font fort
et 7-6 7/5 république elle sent la
naphtaline elle est dépassée aujourd'hui
vous rendez compte que même au premier
tour du coup on ne vote plus pour ces
îles et dès le premier tour on vote pour
celui qui aurait le plus de chance par
dead parmi les deux premiers et donc on
fait déjà barrages dès le premier tour
et donc pour toutes ces raisons je suis
fier d'avoir mené la campagne que nous
avons mené collectivement et elle ne
s'arrête pas là il y à là cinq semaines
de campagne devant nous pour continuer
de porter tous ses espoirs on a bien
compris une dernière question sur le
crâne de juniors with simplement pour
savoir connaître votre avis le président
poutine a mis en garde contre toute
intervention extérieure vous l'avez vu
comme moi promettant qu'elle pourrait
rencontrer une riposte rapide et
foudroyante alors c'est toujours en
effet cette menace nucléaire qui plane
au dessus de l'europe faut-il selon vous
arrêter les livraisons d'armes c'est un
sujet extrêmement sensible
extrêmement préoccupant tous les jours
je suis ça de près et ces nouvelles
menaces d'utilisation de l'armé
nucléaire d'extension du conflit menace
de troisième guerre mondiale tel qu'il
ne sait rien lavrov hier ou avant-hier
est extrêmement préoccupant et donc moi
j'appelle surtout à ce que l'on cesse
l'escaladé guerrière des deux côtés et
que l'on n'arrive à se mettre autour
d'une table pour discuter je regrette
qu'aujourd'hui j'entende les deux
parties craignait ne et et et russes
dire nous allons cesser le dialogue et
les discussions les sirops sachets si on
arrête aussi l'europe et des états unis
arrêtent les livraisons d'armes sa veuve
c'est l'effondrement de l'ukraine est ce
qu'on peut se mettre autour de la table
en ayant justement je veux partir
je souhaite je souhaite qu'il y ait
d'abord un cessez le feu et arrêter
l'escaladé guerrière arrêter l'escaladé
guerrière s'est arrêtée de menacer
d'utiliser l'armé nucléaire c'est faire
attention aussi aux bombardements
puisque j'ai vu qu'il y avait eu des
bombardements ukrainien dans la partie
russe au delà de la frontière
ukrainienne il ya des villes russes qui
ont aussi été bombardés je sens que ça
pousse des deux côtés je sais que
l'ukraine a besoin d'être défendus et
doit être soutenu dans sa défense parce
que c'est lui qui est agressé c'est
l'ukraine qui est agressé qui a été
envahi et je souhaite aussi que l'on
fasse tout pour éviter une troisième
guerre mondiale et puis avec toutes les
question qui va se poser pour l'europe
en termes d'approvisionnement en gaz en
pétrole en céréales enfin c'est
l'ensemble du continent européen qui
reste d'être
embarqué dans une guerre que nous ne
voulons pas merci beaucoup fabien
roussel merci j'avais arrêté notre
invité ce matin on regarde à une de la
voix du nord julien hôtellerie
restauration recherche personnelle
désespérément il ya du travail de
l'autre côté de la route c'est à la une
de votre journal
merci fabien roussel
[Musique]